hey what's going on folks it's actually
been a few days since I made my last
video so I'm pretty anxious to get back
into my groove and start putting out
several videos a week and today I have a
prediction or a theory video for you
guys however you want to label it I
haven't really heard anyone else talk
about this yet and it could be because
it's just [ __ ] but I think Arya
Stark has a real opportunity here to
kill two birds with one stone
given her current situation so I want to
go over what we know and talk about her
current position and tell me if this
makes any sense
but like all predictions we never really
know until we actually see it play out
on screen and now that D and D pretty
much have complete control of where the
story is going we really have no clue
what's going to happen now but let's get
started now the last time we saw Arya
Stark she was at Walder Frey's dinner
party Walder Frey and Jaime Lannister
were celebrating their victory over the
blackfish and them reclaiming house
thali and like many of the Starks Arya
has wanted the phrase dead for a very
long time ever since water Frey set up
her mother and brother to be killed at
the red wedding which Arya luckily
missed being killed at as well if you
remember Arya in the house actually just
showed up as the massacre was taken
place and Arya actually witnessed Rob's
direwolf being killed and shortly after
that they cut off Rob's head they cut
off the direwolf's head they propped
Rob's body up on his horse and they
attached his wolf's head to his body and
paraded him through the little courtyard
right there and Arya actually witnessed
this and was obviously devastated which
any of us would be which would fuel
anyone with the desire and anger to want
to murder every single person that was
involved which we know Arya has planned
on doing for quite some time but she
just never really had the opportunity to
do it until now and after Arya killed
the wife she removed her face and took
it back to the house of black and white
and she added the waves face to the Hall
of faces and when she did this she took
at least one face with her and that's
when she told Jack and a guard she was
going home but on her way home she
decided to make a little pit stop in the
twins at House Frey now that she had
someone else's face she finally had the
opportunity to
get the water free and his sons
undetected so she wore the face to water
phrase little victory celebration and
posed as one of his servants allowing
her to plan her attack right under his
nose without anyone suspecting a thing
now I'm not sure if she expected to see
Jaime Lannister there or not but once
she noticed him sitting there at the
table you could tell she definitely got
excited and most of you probably think
it was because she thought she would now
have the opportunity to kill him too
which is more than likely right but I
think she may have gave Jaime that look
for another reason which I will discuss
shortly but some people think because
Jaime Lannister isn't on Arya's list
then that means she didn't want to kill
him which could be right not likely but
maybe because as far as I know
Arya doesn't know that Jaime pushed
brain out the window because damn near
everyone lady Catelyn told about her
suspicions of the Lannisters doing it
all those people are now dead except for
Theon Greyjoy
so there is a chance that Arya isn't
filled with the same rage to kill Jaime
like she is with Cersei Lannister
but Arya was president Walder Frey as he
gave his victory speech which made it
very clear that Jaime wasn't just
stopping by for a snack but he was
actually working with water Frey in
killing arias family like the blackfish
and as Arya was serving food
Walder stood up and gave his little
speech that went something like for
House Lannister for House Frey and when
we drive our swords through our enemy's
hearts may we speak the words of our
alliance the phrase in the Lannisters
send their regards which had to have
just sent Arya completely over the edge
at that point she probably wishes she
had a machine gun so she could just
spray the entire room with bullets but
shortly after that speech Jaime and
water Frey have a little chitchat and at
one point Walder Frey compared himself
to Jaime because he said they were both
kingslayer's
which didn't sit well with Jaime he did
not like being compared to water Frey at
all Jaime probably thought I may have
killed the king but I did it for a damn
good reason so Jaime was pretty mad he
basically told water what do we even
need you guys for if I have to come down
here and help you take a castle back
every time you
it what's the point of this alliance it
seems kind of one-sided here doesn't it
[ __ ] then Jamie got up and walked away
pretty pissed off
and even though Jamie and Walter were
having the discussion between themselves
I think it's very possible that other
people could have easily heard this or
even after Jamie walked away Walter
could have told one of his kids can you
believe what that prick just said to me
like who the hell is Jamie think he is
coming into my house and mocking me but
either way considering no one knows Arya
was there it puts her in a very good
position to pin these murders on someone
else and that person could be Jaime
[ __ ] Lannister now let me explain as
of right now Walder Frey was the only
person in the world that knows Arya
Stark was at his dinner and he is now
dead so no one's going to have a single
clue who would have murdered all these
phrase no one even knows that Walters
sons are dead yet because if they did
the place would have been in complete
lockdown which would have prevented Arya
from even getting to Walder Frey and
when Arya killed Walter she was the only
one in the dining hall with him so in
the morning when the phrase bodies are
discovered who are they going to think
did it who was all there that would have
had any motive to kill them they
certainly aren't going to think he was
killed by one of his family members or
his own men so who else could have done
it who was the last person that was seen
leaving all pissed off Jaime [ __ ]
Lannister now other than just suspicion
there wouldn't be that much proof that
Jaime did it other than him and Bronn
being there and him leaving all pissed
off
but what if Arya leaves a clue before
she leaves and this clue points the
finger at the Lannisters
imagine if Arya would leave something
that makes it look like Jaime came back
and murdered the phrase after arias let
water phrase throat she could leave a
note right in front of his body where
his plate was sitting and on that note
she could write the Lannisters send
their regards then use the knife she
used to cut his throat and stabbed the
note into the table
leaving the knife standing up sticking
into the note
or she could leave a little lion head or
something like that sitting right next
to his plate or on his lap so when one
of Walter's daughters or servants come
in in the morning to clean up or look
for water they notice the message that
was left behind as if Jaime sent a
message to them like yeah I killed this
piece of [ __ ] and I want you to know it
I mean why not not only could she
scratch the phrase off of her list but
she could also turn the phrase and Elena
stirs against each other which would
cause them to go into war with each
other
weakening both armies I know Aria would
probably like the whole world to know
that the Starks got their vengeance but
if I were her I would take this
opportunity to put another price on
Jamie's head Walder also told Jamie that
after they secured house Tully they
locked ed Muir back up in his cell Aria
should also take this opportunity to
free ed mere as well I know he was kind
of a jackass and screwed us several
things up but he has stole her family
and could come into use one day but
actually when I ask you guys a question
- is there any way that ed meer could
actually take over the phrase army
through his marriage I can't remember
how the line of succession works for
marriages because a report came out a
while back that said aria actually isn't
done killing the phrase while she is
there according to the report at the
beginning of next season we will see or
at least find out during the episode
that Aria killed a few more of the frame
n so if Aria kills every single one of
water sons who would then take control
of the army he has if Ed Muir would be
the last living male in that family even
though his last name isn't frayed could
he then take over the Frey house I can't
remember how that would work out if all
of Walter's heirs were killed so help me
out with that answer if you actually
know it but regardless of what happens
with Ed mirror I think Aria should
absolutely take this opportunity and pin
these murders on Jamie Lannister
causing an all-out war between these two
alliances so tell me what you guys think
this was something that just kind of
popped in my head and I thought oh [ __ ]
like what if when someone discovers
Walters body they see a lion head or a
piece of the Lannister central laying on
Walters lap that Arya purposely left
behind dependent on Jaime I think that
would be pretty cool because even though
she wasn't able to kill Jaime there
that would now send whatever is left of
the phrase after Jaime which would just
add to the even bigger list of people
that are ready to attack the Lannisters
so what if one aria looked at Bronn and
Jaime during the dinner and she gave
Jaime that little smirk what if it was
because she was thinking boy are you
gonna be in for a big surprise in the
morning not only or your business
partners about to be murdered but
they're going to think you did it you
son of a [ __ ] Aria sends her regards
[ __ ] but that's what I got for
you today comment below if you want and
we can discuss this or some other things
whatever you guys want to talk about so
thanks for listening as always and
hopefully I will see you guys in the
comments section bye